If the Universe is full of stars,
why doesn't it appear white?
And if it did, what would it look like?
This is WHAT IF,
and here's what would happen
if the Universe was white instead of black.
Let me break something to you.
Black is not a color...
as far as physics is concerned.
By definition, color is the
visible spectrum of light waves.
A black object absorbs all
the colors in the spectrum,
making "black" an absence of any color.
On the other hand, "white"
is a mixture of all colors,
and it contains all wavelengths of visible light.
Color is about our sensory
perception of the world.
But going back to the
background of the Universe,
you could say it was white once.
When the Universe was
born from the Big Bang,
it didn't have any stars to emit light.
It was opaque with a hot soup
of protons, electrons and neutrons.
After about 300,000 years,
space cooled down
and those particles began pairing up
into atoms and molecules.
The Universe became transparent.
But to you, it would appear absolutely dark.
Because not a single light
source had formed yet.
This was the era of cosmic dark ages.
It ended when the first stars
started fusing hydrogen into helium.
Those stars were up to 300 times
more massive than our Sun,
and a million times brighter.
They shined for a few million years
before they exploded as supernovas.
The growing radiation
from the those first stars
ionized hydrogen atoms -
split them back into
protons and electrons.
That's when the dark Universe lit up,
filled with ultraviolet protons.
So, why didn't it stay that way?
Why with all the new stars and new galaxies,
is our night sky no longer bright?
You see, if the Universe appeared
to be white instead of black,
it would mean that it's infinitely old,
infinitely big and static at the same time.
That would make it a
different Universe altogether.
We know that our Universe is
just under 14 billion years old.
That might seem like
a long time, but remember,
even light has its speed limit.
We can only see stars that are less
than 14 billion light years away from us.
The light from more distant stars
hasn't had the time to reach Earth yet.
As our Universe keeps expanding,
the distance between
stars is increasing, too.
And as distant stars move
further away from us,
the wavelength of their light
increases and shifts towards red.
Until it becomes so long that the
human eye can't see it anymore.
That's another reason for the
black background of the Universe.
Space is filled with all kinds of radiation,
you just can't see it.
And what about the black holes?
Well, even if a very powerful source
of light illuminated our Universe,
you still wouldn't see any black holes.
Those things have such a strong gravity,
that they don't emit any light,
and therefore can never be visible.
Black is, after all, an absence of color.
It would be cool to catch
a black hole one day
and turn it into an infinite energy source.
But that's a story for another WHAT IF.